S
IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT,
PRINCE WILLIAM RESPONDING TO A
BOMBSHELL CASE OF MEDIA
MALPRACTICE INVOLVING HIS
MOTHER, PRINCESS DIANA.
AN INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT BBC
REPORTER MARTIN BASHIR USED
"DECEITFUL TACTICS" IN ORDER TO
SECURE A LANDMARK TELL-ALL
INTERVIEW WITH PRINCESS DIANA
BACK IN 1995.
BENJAMIN HALL IS STANDING BY IN
LONDON WITH ALL THE DETAILS.
BENJAMIN?
>> JESSE, GOOD AFTERNOON, YOU
REMEMBER THIS INTERVIEW FROM
1995, IT WAS GROUNDBREAKING, THE
FIRST TIME PRINCESS DIANA HAD
SPOKEN PUBLICLY ABOUT THE
BREAKDOWN OF HER MARRIAGE TO
PRINCE CHARLES, ABOUT HIS
ADULTERY WITH CAMILLA PARKER
BOWLES, SAYING "THERE WERE THREE
OF US IN THIS RELATIONSHIP, IT
JUST DIDN'T WORK," SHE SPOKE
ABOUT HER RAMP IN BULIMIA AND
MANY PEOPLE FEEL THIS INTERVIEW
LED TO EVENTS THAT LED TO HER
DEATH A COUPLE YEARS LATER.
WHAT IS NOW EMERGES THAT SHE
GAVE THAT INTERVIEW AFTER BEING
SHOWN FORGED BANK DOCUMENTS THAT
MADE IT LOOK AS IF MEMBERS OF
THE ROYAL HOUSE WERE BEING PAID
TO SPY ON HER.
PRINCE WILLIAM RELEASE THE
STATEMENT IN THE LAST FEW
MINUTES SAYING "IT IS MY VIEW
FROM THE DECEITFUL WAY THE
INTERVIEW WAS OBTAINED,
SUBSTANTIALLY INFLUENCE WHAT MY
MOTHER SAID.
THE INTERVIEW WAS A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTION TO MAKING MY
PARENTS RELATIONSHIP WORSE AND
BRINGS INDESCRIBABLE SADNESS TO
KNOW THAT THE BBC'S FAILURE
CONTRIBUTED SIGNIFICANTLY TO HER
FEAR, PARANOIA AND ISOLATION
THAT I REMEMBER FROM THOSE
VALUES WITH HER."
IT WAS ALWAYS THOUGHT STRANGE
THAT PRINCESS DIANA CHOSE MARTIN
BASHIR TO DO THIS INTERVIEW.
NOW IT'S CLEAR SHE DID SO
BECAUSE HE DUPED HER AND ASKED
THE BBC GRAPHICS TEAM TO DRAW UP
THESE FAKE DOCUMENTS TO CONVINCE
HER.
SOME WILL COMPARE THAT 1995
DIANA INTERVIEW TO THE ONE
PRINCE HARRY RECENTLY GAVE TO
OPRAH.
THEY BOTH TALKED ABOUT HOW HARD
THEY FOUND ROYAL LIFE AND HOW IT
AFFECTED OUR MENTAL HEALTH.
THAT INCREDIBLE OPEN, PERSONAL
MESSAGE FROM PRINCE WILLIAM, HE
SAID HE FELT THE MEDIA HOUNDED
HIS MOTHER AND SAID HAD SHE
KNOWN ABOUT THE DECEIT THINGS
MAY HAVE TURNED OUT VERY
DIFFERENTLY.
JESSE?
>> Jesse: THANKS, HANG TIGHT,
WE WANT TO ASK A FEW QUESTIONS
RAY DANA PERINO, GO RIGHT AHEAD.
>> Dana: I KNOW YOU ARE AN
EXPERT ON THIS CASE.
JUST KIDDING.
I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS,
BENJAMIN.
FIRST OF ALL, WHY IN THE WORLD
WAS DIANA'S PR TEAM, I'M SURE
SHE'S NOT MAKING THESE DECISIONS
ON HER OWN, HAVE ASKED FOR HER,
YOU KNOW, BANK RECORDS, WHY...
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
>> FIRST OF ALL, HER TEAM WAS
QUITE DIMINISHED AT THE TIME,
THE ROYAL FAMILY BY ALL ACCOUNTS
HAD RATHER CUT HER OFF AND SHE
WAS LEFT WITH QUITE A SMALL
TEAM, HER BROTHER BEING THE MAIN
ONE AND THIS JOURNALIST, MARTIN
BASHIR APPROACHED HER BROTHER
SAYING, I'VE COME ACROSS THESE
DOCUMENTS WHICH SHOW THAT
MEMBERS OF YOUR HOUSEHOLD AND OF
PRINCESS DIANA'S HOUSEHOLD HAVE
BEEN ACCEPTING MONEY, TOTALING
ABOUT 10,000 POUNDS, $50,000 TO
GIVE INFORMATION ON HER LIFE TO
BOTH THE TABLOIDS AS WELL AS
SECURITY AND IT WAS THAT PIECE
OF INFORMATION THAT ENCOURAGE
DIANA TO GO WITH MARTIN BASHIR.
IT WAS WIDELY REPORTED THAT SHE
WAS WANTING TO GIVE AN INTERVIEW
ANYWAY BUT CERTAINLY NOT TO HIM
AND CERTAINLY THE INTERVIEW
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN, MANY PEOPLE
THINK, AS GROUNDBREAKING AND
SUCH A BIG, OPEN, HONEST
INTERVIEW THAT SHE GAVE.
SHE WAS VERY ANGRY WITH THE
REPORTS THAT MARTIN BASHIR
BROUGHT HER.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT THIS
REPORT THAT THERE WAS A
HANDWRITTEN NOTE THAT SHE WROTE
THAT SAID SHE WAS HAPPY WITH THE
INTERVIEW?
>> SHE DID AND THAT'S WHAT
MARTIN BASHIR CONTINUALLY BRINGS
UP BUT THAT'S BECAUSE THERE HAD
NOT BEEN AN INVESTIGATION AT THE
TIME.
THE BBC HAD AN INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION WHICH SHOWED
MARTIN BASHIR WAS AT FAULT BUT
THEY HELD THAT, THEY COVERED IT
UP, THEY DIDN'T REALLY SET SO
THAT FEELING IS AT THE MOMENT
THAT PRINCESS DIANA JUST DIDN'T
REALIZE THE TRUE EXTENT OF THE
FRAUD THAT WAS PLAYED.
>> Dana: THAT BEING SAID I
WOULD THINK, YOU KNOW, I THINK
IT DIMINISHES HER INTELLIGENCE,
SHE WAS CLEVER AND SHE WAS SMART
AND INTELLIGENT WOMAN AND SHE
PUT IT OUT THERE THAT THERE WERE
THREE PEOPLE IN THE MARRIAGE.
MAYBE THAT WAS HURTFUL, MAYBE
THAT LED TO ADDITIONAL THINGS
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IF YOU
GIVE AN INTERVIEW TO A REPORTER
AT LEAST HERE IT WOULD BE A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
THANKS, BENJAMIN.
>> Kennedy: KENNEDY, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ASK BENJAMIN A QUESTION?
THE MEANS WERE FRAUDULENT IN THE
END WAS UTTERLY TRAGIC FOR THIS
WOMAN, CAN YOU PUT
INTO CONTEXT HOW SHE OBVIOUSLY
WAS THE BRIGHTEST BURNING ROYAL
AT THE TIME.
THERE WAS YEARS AND YEARS OF
GOSSIP ABOUT THE WHALES MARRIAGE
BY WHEN THAT FELL APART IN THIS
INTERVIEW CAME OUT BEFORE,
BEFORE THEY WERE DIVORCED, HOW
DID THAT INTERVIEW CHANGE HOW
SHE WAS PURSUED BY THE PRESS,
HOW DID THAT LEAD INTO HER SON'S
REACTION.
>> SHE WAS THE SHINING STAR OF
THE ROYAL FAMILY AT THE TIME.
HE WAS THE HEIR TO THE THRONE,
THE ONE I WAS SUPPOSED TO GET
ALL THE ATTENTION AND
PRINCESS DIANA WAS THE PEOPLE'S
PRINCESS, THE ONE THE PEOPLE
TURNED TO SO WHEN THE DIVORCE OR
WHEN THE MARRIAGE BROKE DOWN,
PEOPLE STARTED TO SIDE WITH HER
AND THEY DIDN'T LIKE THAT.
AS SOON AS SHE SPOKE TO THE
PRESS, SHE KIND OF CROSS THAT
LINE, ROYALS TEN TO BE GIVEN
SOME SCENT OF PRIVILEGE IN THE
U.K. BUT WHEN SHE CAME OUT AND
GET THAT BIG INTERVIEW IT WAS
ALMOST AS IF THE GLOVES CAME OFF
AND SHE WAS FAIR GAME FOR THE
REST OF THE PRESS AND AT THAT
POINT WE STARTED TO SEE THEM
HOUND HER, NOT ONE OR TWO
PAPARAZZI BUT HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS AT A TIME FOLLOWING HER
EVERYWHERE SHE WENT AND SHE WAS
NOT GIVEN SUPPORT OR SECURITY BY
THE ROYAL FAMILY.
THE COUNTER SIDE TO THIS IS THAT
SHE VERY CLEVERLY USED IN THE
MEDIA, SHE KNEW SHE WAS HEADING
INTO A DIVORCE BATTLE AND KNEW
SHE NEEDED TO IMPROVE HER OWN
STANDING SO SHE WAS OFF ALSO
KNOWN TO GIVE TIPOFFS TO THE
MEDIA AND THE TABLETS WHEN IT
SUITED HER AND OFTEN DIDN'T WANT
THE ATTENTION WHEN IT WAS BAD SO
LOOK, THERE ARE TWO SIDES TO
HOW PRINTS DIANA INTERACTED TO
THE MEDIA BUT JOURNALISTIC
MALPRACTICE IS SUCH AS FORGING
DOCUMENTS TO GET AN INTERVIEW.
>> Jesse: JUAN WILLIAMS, WHY
DON'T YOU JUMP IN HERE?
>> Juan: THIS WEEK THERE WAS
NEWS HERE IN THE U.S. ONE
PRINCE HARRY, I GUESS, SAID HE
THINKS THE FIRST AMENDMENT HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES IS
CONFUSING TO HIM, HE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND IT AND I KNOW THAT
FLEET STREET IS FAMOUS IN
BRITAIN FOR ITS AGGRESSIVE
TACTICS, TAPPING PHONES AND ALL
THE REST BUT IS THERE A
DIFFERENT SET OF RULES JUST FOR
US AS AMERICANS TO UNDERSTAND AS
WE TAKE IN THE STORY?
IS THERE A DIFFERENT SET OF
PROTECTION FOR PUBLIC FIGURES
LIKE DIANA THAT ARE BEING
APPLIED IN THIS BBC REPORT?
>> THE ROYAL FAMILY, WOULD GIVE
X AMOUNT OF MEDIA ON EVENTS A
YEAR AND THAT HAVE BEEN A
LONG-STANDING AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE PRESS AND THE ROYAL FAMILY.
THAT STARTED TO CHANGE AND I
THINK WE SEEN THAT THE WORLD
OVER, SOCIAL MEDIA ALSO STARTED
TO MEAN THAT, THAT CAME A BIT
LATER BUT THEY WERE EVERYWHERE
AND PAPARAZZI, THE '90s WERE
THE HEYDAY OF PAPARAZZI, THE
U.K. PRESS COULD NO LONGER
CONTROL IT AND THERE WAS A BIG
DISCUSSION AS TO WHETHER, IF
THESE PHOTOS WERE BEING TAKEN SO
OFTEN IN PUBLISHER ON THE WORLD,
WHY SHOULD THE U.K. PRESS ALSO
HAVE TO BE SILENCED AND NOT BE
ABLE TO PUBLISH THEM?
SO WE STARTED TO SEE A
RELATIONSHIP CHANGE BETWEEN THE
ROYAL FAMILY AND THE MEDIA.
YOU TALK ABOUT PRINCE HARRY AND
I THINK MANY PEOPLE SAY HE IS
JUST AS SAVVY AS HIS MOTHER WAS
WHEN IT COMES TO USING THE MEDIA
AND WE SEEN THAT NOW, HE CALLED
THE FIRST AMENDMENT "BONKERS,"
IT'S SURPRISING THAT
PRINCE WILLIAM WAS THE FIRST
WANT TO COME OUT WITH A
STATEMENT, IT'S ALMOST ALWAYS
HARRY WHO IS QUICKLY ON
INSTAGRAM OR TWITTER WITH HIS
REPLIES.
INTERESTINGLY WE WILL SEE THE
TWO BROTHERS TOGETHER ON THE 1SE
BEEN PRINCESS DIANA'S 60TH
BIRTHDAY AND THEY ARE UNVEILING
A STATUE TOGETHER AND IT WILL BE
THE FIRST TIME WE'VE SEEN THEM
SINCE PRINCE PHILIP'S FUNERAL
AND THE BIG RIFT HAS CONTINUED
TO WIDEN SO ALL EYES WILL BE ON
THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE ARE TWO
DIFFERENT CAMPS OF THE MOMENT,
WILLIAM COMES OUT RATHER MORE
RESTRAINED STATEMENT AND THEN
YOU HAVE HARRY WITH A FAR MORE
EMOTIONAL ONE.
SOME PEOPLE FEEL HE'S REALLY
FOLLOWING THE DIANA MODEL BUT
THE STATEMENT FROM
PRINCE WILLIAM WAS EMOTIONAL AND
RAW TO THE CORE, HE TALKED ABOUT
THE PAIN AND THE SUFFERING THAT
THIS INTERVIEW CAUSED HIM SO I
THINK WE ARE SEEING A GAME
PLAYER BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM,
PRINCE WILLIAM DOESN'T WANT
PRINCE HARRY TO BE THE ONE WHO
CARRIES THE MANTLE OF HIS
MOTHER, HE WANTS TO REMIND THE
WORLD THAT SHE WAS HIS MOTHER,
TOO AND HE IS JUST AS MUCH OF A
RIGHT TO HER SO IT'S AN
INTERESTING BATTLE PLAYING OUT
BETWEEN THE TWO BROTHERS.
WE WILL BE WATCHING WHEN THEY
COME BACK TOGETHER AGAIN ON JUL.
TO WILLIAM'S STATEMENT ACTUALLY
INCLUDED THE PHRASE "FAKE NEWS"
WHICH I HAD TO DO A LITTLE BIT
OF A DOUBLE TAKE THERE, I DIDN'T
KNOW THAT IT BECOME SO POPULAR
ACROSS THE POND, BENJAMIN.
KATIE WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU A
QUESTION SO STICK WITH THEIR PAY
KATIE?
>> Katie: BENJAMIN, YOU'RE
MENTIONING THIS RIVALRY THAT
SEEMS TO BE BREWING BETWEEN THE
TWO BROTHERS AND COLOR ME
SUSPICIOUS BUT THIS IS AN
INDEPENDENT INQUIRY, CAN YOU
PLEASE TALK ABOUT WHO WAS BEHIND
THE INDEPENDENT INQUIRY?
BECAUSE THIS INTERVIEW TOOK
PLACE 26 YEARS AGO AND I YOU
HAVE HARRY IN THE U.S. WORKING
WITH OPRAH, HEADLINE THIS WEEK
SAYING HE WAS GOING TO DROP MORE
"TRUTH BOMBS" ABOUT THE ROYAL
FAMILY SO WHO IS BEHIND THE
INVESTIGATION AND WHY IS IT
COMING OUT NOW?
>> THERE HAD LONG BEEN RUMORS
THAT THIS INTERVIEW WAS BASED ON
FRAUDULENT REPORTING.
THE BBC DID ITS OWN INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION ABOUT 25 YEARS AGO
AND THEY COVERED IT UP.
THIS NEW INVESTIGATION CAME AS
THE INQUIRY HEADED OUT BY LAURA
DYSON, CAME ABOUT BECAUSE OF
CHANGES IN THE MEDIA THAT WE ARE
SEEING.
WE HAD THE PHONE HACKING SCANDAL
THAT TOOK PLACE TEN YEARS AGO
AND A NUMBER OF THEM BROUGHT
BACK AND INVESTIGATED, AS A
RESULT THIS HAS COME TO LIFE AND
BEEN ACCEPTED BY THE BBC WHO
ALWAYS DENIED IT.
THERE WILL BE RAMIFICATIONS WE
JUST DON'T KNOW AT THE MOMENT
BUT THE PRESS ARE BEING HELD TO
ACCOUNT MORE AND MORE OVER HERE.
YOU MENTIONED THE PHONE HACKING,
WHICH TOOK PLACE AROUND TEN
YEARS AGO, THAT ABSOLUTELY
CHANGED THE WAY THE MEDIA WAS
SEEN OVER HERE.
IT WAS THE WILD WEST FOR THEM,
THEY WERE HACKING INTO
PRINCE HARRY'S VOICE MAIL, THE
VOICE MAILS WERE JUST GENERIC
PASSWORDS AND ALL THIS
INFORMATION IS BEING FLASHED
OVER TO THE NEWSPAPERS AND THEY
REALLY CRACKED DOWN ON THAT AND
WHAT WE ARE SEEING NOW, FRANKLY,
IS THE MEDIA CONTINUING TO TRY
TO CLEAN THEMSELVES UP AND
PERHAPS ADDRESS OLD MISTAKES.
>> Jesse: THANKS A LOT,
BENJAMIN.
I GUESS IT'S TRUE THAT MEDIA
CORRUPTION HAS NO BORDERS.
AND PRINCE HARRY HAS RELEASED A
STATEMENT SAYING "TO THOSE WHO
HAVE TAKEN SOME FORM OF
ACCOUNTABILITY, THANK YOU FOR
OWNING IT.
THAT IS THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS
JUSTICE AND TRUTH.
BUT DEEPLY CONCERNS ME IS THAT
PRACTICES LIKE THESE AND EVEN
WORSE ARE STILL WIDESPREAD
TODAY, THEN AND NOW, IT'S BIGGER
THAN ONE OUTLET, ONE NETWORK OR
ONE PUBLICATION.
MY BIGGEST CONCERN WAS HISTORY
REPEATING ITSELF.
I'VE SAID THAT BEFORE ON
NUMEROUS OCCASIONS VERY PUBLICLY
AND WHAT I WAS SEEING WAS
HISTORY REPEATING ITSELF UP
MORE, PERHAPS, WERE DEFINITELY
FAR MORE DANGEROUS BECAUSE THEN
YOU ADD RACE IN AND YOU HAD
SOCIAL MEDIA IN HAND WHEN I'M
TALKING ABOUT HISTORY REPEATING
ITSELF I AM TALKING ABOUT MY
MOTHER."
VERY INTERESTING THAT